[Musique]
toute une tempête médiatique et au
déluge de commentaires récemment en lien
avec les affirmations controversée de
récipiendaire du prix nobel de médecine
le biologiste et virologues luc
montagnier ce modèle on a par dessus a
ajouté des séquences notamment du vih
pour en arriver à cette conclusion
monsieur montanier se base entre autres
sur une étude préliminaire d'une équipe
de chercheurs indiens qui fait état
d'une séquence génétique similaire entre
le virus qui causent à kobe 19 le strass
cov 2 et certaines souches du vih
pour sa part monsieur montagne et y voit
la preuve que le nouveau coronavirus
auraient été créées en laboratoire bayer
un petit problème
cette interprétation n'a jamais été mise
de l'avant par les auteurs de l'étude à
laquelle se réfère monsieur montanier ce
n'était pas notre intention d'alimenter
les théories du complot et aucune
affirmation à cet effet n'a été fait ici
c'est ce qu'a dit prashant pradhan
auteur principal de l'étude sur l'astra
skov 2 et le vih le virologue québécois
benoit barbeau spécialisé dans l'étude
du vih note que la séquence génétique
quelques l'asra skov 2 et le vih ont en
commun est infime et se retrouve dans
bon nombre d'autres virus la goutte de
chercheur indien très très renommé avait
publié
la même chose on les a forcés à
rétracter je rappelle que l'étude à la
source de cette affaire n'a jamais été
publiée dans une revue scientifique
révisé par les pairs dès sa mise en
ligne sur un site dit de prépublication
plusieurs chercheurs ont souligné que
l'étude comportait des failles
contrairement à ce qu'a affirmé le
professeur luc montagnier dans cette
entrevue les auteurs n'ont pas été
forcés de la retirer mais ils ont plutôt
choisi de le faire de leur plein gré en
admettant qu'elle nécessitait tout
simplement plus de travail
un petit mot maintenant sur le
professeur montagnier si vous le
permettez
il est critiqué depuis un bon nombre
d'années pour une kyrielle
d'affirmations contraire à la science
autre bémol a souligné à son sujet en
une quarantaine de prix nobel ont signé
une pétition contre le professeur
montagnier en affirmant et je cite qu'il
accumule les impostures scientifique et
médicale alors pour plus de détails sur
cet épineux dossier
jetez un coup d'oeil à l'article signé
par ma collègue de bouchra wathier et
n'oubliez pas de consultez notre groupe
facebook et pourquoi pas y adhérer aussi
allez salut
[Musique]